[Music]
the 2022 American Music Awards
celebrated their 50th Anniversary last
night and the red carpet was full of
generations of talent but it was Taylor
Swift who became the top awarded artist
in ama's history sweeping last night
with six wins bringing her career total
to 40. I can't thank you enough for
caring about this album that I'm so
proud of now the award show didn't
Escape controversy as the crowd erupted
in booze after Kelly Rowland announced
Chris Brown one favorite R B artist
Chris Brown
foreign
is not here tonight so I'm accepting
this award on his behalf excuse me ciao
chill out Chris took to Instagram and
said that he was supposed to put on a
tribute for Michael Jackson at the award
show but claims it was canceled for
reasons unknown but the night was still
full of tributes including pink honoring
Olivia Newton-John
and
Dove Cameron using her acceptance speech
to address the recent lgbtq plus club
shooting in Colorado on the heels of the
tragedy that happened to Club Q in
Colorado Springs I want to remind
everyone how important queer visibility
is and how important our community is
BTS at a record after winning favorite
pop duo or group for the fourth time
making them the most awarded group in
history of the category which had fans
loving every minute now from the amas to
the star power at this year's Governor's
award where Cher presented songwriter
Diane Warren with an honorary Oscar I am
so thrilled to present this to you
you've waited so long
[Applause]
he sure doesn't go east of the 405 for
anybody this is a big thing and Michael
J fox was awarded the Academy Awards
Gene hirschelt humanitarian award for
his advocacy work that has raised over
1.5 billion dollars for Research into
Parkinson's disease you're making me
shake
seven I heard an expression the other
day I never heard before someone said oh
they were 80s famous
that was a different deal
[Music]